vous croyez corps parfait mais bientôt
vous verrez que chaque son chaque mois
et elle estime hertz valigot les bacs au
bureau local toi le noir ah ben ouais je
vois ce week-end son permis lui pour lui
dans des marches cette fois je gagne je
sais tu te cacher ses cortex attention
alors
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est un goûter
la régie en bout tard les mecs si trop
dark et s'il ya de la fumée partout
bon là est celle du mat merde j'avoue
bongo est question ni tours jumelles et
surtout personnes et a fait telle arme
prête à présenter c'est bien que mal
effectué le soir ça fait trop du bien
petit conseil si bordel c'est pas
possible c'est ridiculement nous
projetons serre et sans trop savoir quoi
tu joues bien mais douchez la compagnie
a regretté mon vista vous souhaitons un
agréable crash ne vole pas mais qu'est
ce que c'est que cette manière même ce
président je crois pas qu'on soit le 1er
avril
l'attraction contrat dont trois deux un
cépage et rubio tu vois leur toit non
pas du tout hébert pourquoi car de faire
chier avec leur tenait tellement beau
aussi dit toujours pas dire je sais tu
continues tu te ferait trop tôt donc une
hausse qui l'a pas non plus lui mais
c'est quoi ta compte 1 0 aux mirages
loser et la bd dur mais je crois que
c'est populaire payer après toi coco je
soutiens le plus rapide de l'ouest rien
à [ __ ] ça avait bien prévenu peut-être
d'oignons c'est mon recueil aquitaine
vers la mi temps c'est marrant mais je
voudrais bonnes questions et donc au
maire du cateau ma mère ça va chier pour
moi s'ils vont s'arrêter mais soulève
cette chanson s'appelle un peu 500 km
[ __ ] je sois je vais pas la foire aux
abats si c'est bon j'ai eu à la windows
error 404 tous à couvert moi d'avoir son
sein beaucoup plus tard débrouillez-vous
ras du sol avec un avion mais c'est qui
encore ce baiser de la vie j'en sais
rien savoir que ce qui est content avec
ce qui lui arrive
vous êtes déjà dit pas que les
limitations des tests ou les cartes plus
tard mais dégage suède
on rappelle qu'en chaise escalade à
l'école etc en fout ta vie tu vois non
il est où est juste en dessous bordel je
dis je vois pas vraiment merde gérant
des membres des trois soleils couchants
le symbole arz aucun ne soit trop tard
je vais courir vers la main il m'a dit
qu'ils étaient pressés d'aller aux
toilettes je suis qu'un traité ma mère
c'est toi [ __ ] ça fait quatre ans que
j'attends qu'on fait cette attraction
merde [ __ ] vouloir équiper d'un
pistolet mais pour la première fois un
troll je me présente son nouvel avion
sans toit à mettre ce que c'est pas
dangereux et non t'inquiète c'est quand
même pas trop me tombera mûri
on en a marre à ma maman papa
call of conneries modern warfare 3 le
jeu dont les sons sont entièrement faits
avec la bouche